quand la France a connu une pénurie de
moutarde cet été le bof semenyuka
rapidement développé une nouvelle gamme
de produits
on a réussi à partiellement remplacer
ses pertes en exportant vers la France
il y avait une pénurie de graines
ailleurs donc on s'en est bien sorti
Russes et les coupures d'électricité
difficile de rester compétitif
parfois on doit utiliser le générateur
pendant 8 ou 10 heures ça nous revient
presque deux fois plus cher que le coût
de l'électricité en temps normal
elle s'estime néanmoins heureuse d'avoir
ce générateur acheter il y a 2 ans
les entreprises
qui
et qui disent des pertes importantes
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup en vert
craignant que son fournisseur local ne
se retrouvent obligés de cesser de les
produire faute d'énergie
leur production
certaines ont fermé
reconstruire l'économie ce sera un vrai
défi parce qu'il y aura des manques de
trésorerie
selon le fournisseur ukrainien d'énergie
même si les frères russes cessaient les
coupures de rationnement d'électricité
devrait se poursuivre pendant plusieurs
semaines se rajoutons à de nombreux
autres facteurs nuisant à l'économie
ukrainienne pendant cette guerre les
experts prédisent une récession de plus
de 40% cette année